[Musik]
wir warten auf euch wird auf die alte
stadtmauer in jerusalem projiziert
israel bietet sich als vermittler im
ukraine krieg an es gibt hoffnung dass
es dort zu einem direkten treffen der
präsidenten salewski und putin kommen
könnte die verhandlungen zwischen der
ukraine und russland laufen also weiter
aber auch die angriffe auf ukrainische
städte und das mit zunehmender härte
immer mehr zivilisten werden verletzt
oder getötet
willkommen zu einem kurzen zdf spezial
wieso beginnt etwa 15 minuten später
es fehlt offenbar nicht mehr viel zur
von russland angestrebten land
verbindungen zwischen der halbinsel krim
im süden und dem don bass im osten die
400.000 einwohner stadt mario pohl liegt
in diesem korridor und ist deshalb von
russischen truppen eingekesselt und
unter schwerem beschuss flucht korridor
für die menschen funktionieren mal und
dann wieder nicht auch die
versorgungslage in der stadt wird immer
schlechter achim flur
dutzende schwarze rauchsäulen über mario
pohl jeder ein raketen oder
bombentreffer jede steht für verheerende
zerstörung und tod russische truppen
haben die stadt eingekesselt beschießen
sie seit tagen mit aller macht denn
mario pohl ist ein wichtiges
strategisches ziel im russischen
vormarsch plan
die hafenstadt ist die letzte große
stellung die die ukraine am asowschen
meer noch halten nach dem fall von
person und milito pol ein letztes
hindernis um eine sichere landverbindung
zwischen dem don bass und der krim zu
schaffen das würde es russischen
militärplaner erlauben truppen und
material im süden und südosten der
ukraine schneller zu verlegen russische
stellen melden dass es diese landbrücke
bereits gebe noch leisten die ukraine
widerstand diese bilder aus ukrainischen
quellen sollen den angriff auf russische
panzer fahrzeuge am stadtrat von mario
pohl zeigen
in den trümmern der stadt sind über
400.000 menschen gefangen lebensmittel
wasser und medikamente gehen zur neige
heute kündigt die russische seite ein
ende der blockade und die
massenevakuierung mario pools an 160
autos mit zivilisten hätten die stadt
bereits verlassen ein paar hundert
hoffnung oder wieder nur eine
ankündigung bisherige vereinbarungen
über flucht korridore aus mario pohl
wurden bis gestern nicht gehalten
leider wurde der korridor mariupol
blockiert wieder wir haben alles
notwendige getan waffenruhe garantiert
und aber russische truppen haben die
bewegung von bussen und fragt gespürt
aber wir werden es wieder versuchen bis
ihr unseren leuten helfen können sie
gehören zu uns unser mario pohl
heroisches mario bros
für mario pohl schreibt ein ukrainischer
soldat auf eine panzergranate auch die
soll töten und zerstören der name der
stadt wird zusehends zu einem symbol für
die ukraine für durchhaltewillen aber
auch für die schrecken des krieges nach
ukrainischen angaben hat die russische
offensive auf mario pohl bisher über
2100 menschen leben gekostet
in berlin begrüße ich den militär
historiker sönke neitzel guten abend
mario pohl ist eingekesselt eingekesselt
wir haben es gerade gesehen und seit
tagen unter schweren beschuss wenn die
russischen streitkräfte die stadt
besetzen dann steht auch die
landverbindung von der krim bis ins don
was ist dass putins wichtigstes
kriegsziel ich würde sagen ist es ein
kriegsziel aber es geht natürlich in
diesem krieg um viel mehr es geht nicht
nur um den dom bass und eine
landverbindung zu geben sondern es geht
darum putin geht es darum der ganzen
ukraine seinen willen aufzuzwingen und
das ist letztlich das kriegsziel und da
ist mario pohl und die landverbindung
nur letztlich ein kleiner teil ein
kleiner schritt auf diesem weg dahin
heute hat erstmals ein vertrauter putins
der chef seiner nationalgarde eingeräumt
das zitat nicht alles so schnell geht
wie wir es gerne hätten der
verteidigungsminister dagegen sagt alles
laufe nach plan wer hat recht
der chef der nationalgarde ganz
eindeutig hat recht am anfang war es so
dass putin ja vor hatte einen schnellen
ich sage meinen anführungsstrichen
enthauptungsschlag zu führen wenige tage
um dann die ukraine zu besetzen die
regierung auszustatten das ist
gescheitert und jetzt müssen die ukraine
müssten die russischen streitkräfte um
organisieren müssen einen großen krieg
führen gegen den ukrainischen
streitkräfte dabei geht eine menge
schief aber wir sollten auch die
russischen streitkräfte nicht
unterschätzen wir sehen dass sie lernen
und meines erachtens ist der ausgang
dieses krieges nach wie vor offen es war
ja ein überfall auf die gesamte ukraine
der westen des landes aber war nie
russisch heißt das dass es nicht gut ins
ziel ist den auch zu kontrollieren na ja
die frage ist immer was heißt wann ab
wann war also russisch also im lemberg
und die region wurde 1939 russisch und
ich glaube in der vorstellung putins
geht es in der tat um die ganze ukraine
und der seinen willen aufzuzwingen um
sie zu identifizieren
entmilitarisierten und das betrifft auch
die region um lemberg rechnen sie mit
einer weiteren ausweitung der angriffe
in den nächsten tagen ja unbedingt
leider muss man sagen putin kann sich
einfach eine militärische niederlage
oder einen part nicht leisten für ist
auch das militär zu wichtig der
militärische erfolg innenpolitisch für
seine machtstellung und er ist zum
erfolg zum taktischen erfolg verdammt
und deswegen glaube ich dass er mit der
brechstange arbeiten wird das heißt mehr
militärische feuerkraft mehr tote
zivilisten mehr gewalt danke bis hierher
wir sprechen gleich nochmal
der freie journalist arndt ginzel ist
heute von süden kommend in die
hauptstadt kiew gefahren dort haben er
und sein team hilfsaktionen begleitet
und die lebensbedingungen in der
belagerten stadt miterlebt hier sein
bericht
ein vorort von kiew etwa 20 kilometer
westlich des stadtzentrums die menschen
leben hier im keller
etwa als passiver mit ihrer familie
einige nachbarn 17 menschen insgesamt
erwachsene kinder seit 18 tagen
wir haben angst in den wohnungen oben zu
leben
wegen der bomben gehen morgen nachts
gehören erst die ganze zeit
anders man muss im land bleiben noch
muss er nicht kämpfen verlassen wollen
sie ihn nicht
ein leben aus der plastiktüte morgens
versuchen sie etwas einzukaufen
das ganze leben spielt sich hier unten
hat
wir wissen nicht was uns noch erwartet
es ist ein krieg gegen die
zivilbevölkerung gegen die kleinen
kinder
die kinder wohnen und schlafen hier
anders töchter und ein nachbarsjunge
sie malen meistens und sie können nicht
verstehen warum es diesen krieg gibt
ein bild mit den nationalflaggen
russlands und der ukraine und ein wunsch
sie hat wirklich angst zu sterben
im sommer wollten wir in die türkei
reisen
mit der ganzen familie wollten wir
dorthin reisen wir wollen doch nicht
sterben wir wollen doch nur so leben wie
zuvor
warten schlafen ungewissheit
und den kleinsten irgendwie ein gefühl
geben von normalität und
in kiew ist uns jetzt arndt ginzel
zugeschaltet guten abend und
sie sind mit ihrem team von dessau nach
kiew gefahren was haben sie gesehen und
wie abgeregelt ist die hauptstadt
mittlerweile
ja wir sind noch gut reingekommen in die
stadt das funktioniert auf einen auf der
gegenfahrbahn haben wir gesehen dass
relativ wenig verkehr war
interessanterweise es ja die spur auf
der viele menschen fahren um
rauszukommen aus der stadt man sieht
dass die menschen hier alles tun um die
um die kranken beziehungsweise die
außenbereiche der stadt zu sichern es
werden sandsäcke übereinander gestapelt
es wären barrikaden gebaut
schikanen auf den straßen also die
menschen versuchen die stadt abzuriegeln
dass mein eindruck aber man kommt rein
und man kommt raus sagt ja
granatbeschuss außenbezirke von kiew
gegeben dabei waren auch tote zu
beklagen wie ist denn die lage im moment
in der stadt ist es ruhig
also wir sind im zentrum der stadt
hinter mir sieht man den meiden
es ist jetzt ruhig ich kann hier jetzt
im augenblick nichts hören von von
irgendwelchen detonation die waren noch
etwa vor anderthalb zwei stunden im
nördlichen bereich der stadt dort ist es
ein permanent hörbarer ton manchmal hört
ständig detonation man hört ständig
granatbeschuss also das ist für für für
ein wenn man weiter draußen ist durchaus
wahrnehmbar sie waren ja schon zu beginn
des krieges in der ukraine damals noch
im donbass im osten wie hat sich dann
die stimmung seither verändert
na ja zu der zeit war noch weitaus mehr
menschen in der stadt also die
straßenbahn noch voll
das änderte sich dann als der krieg
begann man sagen große staus viele
menschen die die stadt verlassen wollten
ich habe jetzt so den eindruck
dass die stadt ist weitgehend leer man
sieht weitaus mehr männer in uniform in
der stadt und es ist eine beängstigende
stille würde ich sagen nachts die
russische seite droht ja damit auch
große städte einzunehmen ist das
realistisch
wenn man mit experten spricht mit
militärexperten spricht die sagen ja so
eine stadt wie tief das ist ein alptraum
für angreifer es ist unheimlich
kompliziert hier rein zu gehen
schließlich haben die verteidiger auch
einige vorteile sie kennen die stadt wir
haben erlebt dass es hier in den parks
und an vielen stellen
stellungen der armee gibt es sind
schützengräben gegraben worden die leute
sind hier vorbereitet auf eine mögliche
auf einen möglichen sturm auf die stadt
und das dürfte es den angreifern sehr
schwer machen also die leute hier sagen
sie glauben daran die stadt verteidigen
zu können vielen dank für das gespräch
und gänse bleiben sie sicher
gerne danke das gespräch haben wir vor
einer stunde aufgezeichnet und jetzt ist
uns nochmal der militärhistoriker sönke
neitzel zugeschaltet was verändert
dieser krieg für die sicherheit in
europa
ja ich glaube dass es seit dem 24
februar 2022 keine gewissheit gibt es
ist das ende der gewissheiten wir
glaubten ja dass krieg mit uns in europa
eigentlich nichts zu tun hat krieg ist
eine sache die in fernen gegenden
stattfindet und wir müssen wieder lernen
wie europäer aber wir deutschen ganz
besonders ja die landes- und
bündnisverteidigung zu denken die wir ja
in den letzten 30 jahren eigentlich
vernachlässigt und vergessen haben und
es ist jetzt wichtig dass es den
politischen willen gibt eine institution
wie die bundeswehr auch wieder
einsatzbereit zu machen und ein stück
weit immer das schlimme wort auch wieder
kriegs bereit zu machen putin hat ja mit
diesem krieg sicher ohne es zu wollen
bewirkt dass eu und nato so eng
zusammengerückt sind wie lange nicht
mehr was hat das für folgen ja es ist
glaube ich für die europäer und für die
nato die eu eine eine chance nicht mann
war in der nato wir denken an marco und
der hirntod aber auch viele probleme
gerade in der sicherheitspolitik im
bereich der eu und ich glaube man kann
das als chance begreifen dass wir unsere
wertegemeinschaft auch verteidigen
müssen dass wir zusammenstehen das ist
dann die kraft unserer idee ist die wir
gegen autokraten diktatoren der welt
eben auch verteidigen müssen dass wir
die partikularinteressen gerade in der
sicherheitspolitik denken wir an schon
frankreich wie schwierig das war dass
wir das endlich überwinden und gemeinsam
sicherheitspolitisch an einem strang
ziehen vielen dank für das gespräch sei
sehr gerne
wenn auch sie die menschen in der
ukraine oder auf der flucht unterstützen
wollen dann können sie spenden an das
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine bahn.de
65 104 106 100 104 106 100 alle infos
auch unter spenden zdf de oder im zdf
text auf seite 8 190
inmitten der heftigen kämpfe laufen
gespräche auf vielen ebenen die türkei
israel und andere bieten sich als
vermittler bundeskanzlers und präsident
makro haben zweimal in den letzten drei
tagen mit putin telefoniert
immerhin diese kanäle also gibt es und
damit auch die hoffnung dass die waffen
irgendwann hoffentlich bald schweigen
und ernsthafte verhandlungen möglich
werden
vielen dank für ihr interesse hier geht
es jetzt weiter mit wiso auf wiedersehen
[Musik]